امام مجمع الشفاء الطبي هناك مراسل
الجزيره هشام زقوط مجددا معنا هشام اذا ما
اخر حصيله لاعداد الضحايا
سفيان
[موسيقى]
نعم هشام سفيان نعم حتى الان عدد الشهداء
مستقر حتى الى حد ثلاثه عشر شهيدا
وعدد من الاصابات من بعدها من بعض هذه
الاصابات هي اصابات خطيره نحن نتواجد هنا
في هذا المجمع مجمع شفاء الطبي وهو اكبر
المستشفيات في قطاع غزه وقد وصلت اليه
اغلب
الاصابات وايضا الشهداء هنا امام ثلاجه
الشهداء يتجمع عدد من الاهالي وايضا عدد
غفير من المواطنين حيث يجري الاستعداد
لنقل جتامين الشهداء الى المسجد حيث
يصلى عليها صلاه الظهر ومن ثم يتم نقلها
الى مقبره الشهداء حيث حيث ستوارى هناك
هنا في هذا المجمع يتواجد على الاقل عدد
العدد الاكبر من الشهداء ما عدا شهداء رفح
وهم الشهيد القائد في سرايا القدس جهاد
الغنام وايضا زوجته وفاء الغنام
وبالاضافه الى هؤلاء الشهداء يتواجد هنا
عدد من الشهداءهم
القائد في سرايا القدس ايضا طارق عز الدين
وخليل البهتيني وكذلك عدد من عائلاتهم
وجيرانهم نحن قبل ان ناتي الى هنا الى
مجمع الشفاء الطبي كنا قد ذهبنا الى منزل
خليل البهتيني القيادي في سرايا القدس
والذي قصف فيه واستشهد هناك جراء اغتياله
من قبل الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
وكان هناك جزء كبير من المنزل مدمر وايضا
كانت بعض المنازل المحيطه بهذا المنزل في
حي التفاح شرق مدينه غزه مدمره جراء هذا
القصف على ما يبدو ان قصف عنيف استهد هذا
المنزل دمار كبير وواسع حله بالمنزل
والمنازل المحيطه نحن نتحدث عن حي مقتض
وحي المنازل فيه متلاصقه وكانت كما نعرف
العمليه وعمليه الاغتيال المتزامنه بدات
تقريبا عند الثانيه بعد منتصف الليل
والناس نيام وبالتالي كان عدد الاصابات
كبيرا ونقلوا الى هذا المشفى بالاضافه الى
ذلك مررنا الى الشقه السكنيه التي كان
يتواجد فيها ويسكن فيها طارق عز الدين
القيادي في حركه الجهد الاسلامي والقائد
في سرايا القدس وايضا كان هناك دمار كبير
حل بهذه بهذا المبنى السكني هي عباره عن
عماره سكنيه من عده طوابق
وجميع ربما الشقق السكنيه تضررت بفعل هذا
القصر اذا اضرار كبيره اعداد واسعه من
الشهداء والجرحى جراء هذا عمليه الاغتيال
التي بدات عند الثانيه من منتصف الليل
واستمرت بقصف عدد من المواقع
التابعه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه الناس هنا
تصر رغم سوء الاوضاع الامنيه
والاستمرار التحليق المكثف للطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي في سماء القطاع الا ان
الجماهير تصر على تشييع هؤلاء
القاده وايضا الشهداء المدنيين الذين
سقطوا واستشهدوا جراء هذه الغارات
الاسرائيليه كنا قد التقينا ايضا
بمد الدكتور محمد ابو سلميه المدير مجمع
شفاء الطبي وتحدث عن وضع هذه الاصابات
والكثير منها خضع لعمليات منهم من
استشهدوا ومنهم ما زالت العمليات جاريه
حتى الان وهناك مكثفه للجنه الطوارئ
التابعه لوزاره الصحه تتدارس الاوضاع
خاصه في ظل سوء
والنقص الحاد في الادويه والمستلزمات
الطبيه التي تعاني منها وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه جراء الحصار المتواصل على قطاع
غزه منذ 15 عاما اذا هي حاله سيئه التصعيد
الاسرائيلي جاء مباغتا للجميع وكانت
والاوضاع في القطاع بشكل عام هي سيئه
والجميع بانتظار ماذا ستحمل الساعات
القادمه
هشام ماذا عن الاجتماع الطارئ الذي تنوي
وزاره الصحه عقده
سفيان تجتمع الان
يعني عدد من
الاطباء والمسؤولين في وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه وهي لجنه الطوارئ التي شكلت
وتجتمع بشكل خاص وعاجل عند حدوث اي تصعيد
اسرائيلي او حدوث اي امر طارئ في قطاع غزه
وتتدارس كيف ستدير وزاره الصحه هذه الازمه
في ظلمه تعانيهم النقص حاد في الادويه
والمستلزمات الطبيه هذا الاجتماع بدا
تقريبا عند التاسعه والنصف وحتى الان هو
مستمر ولم تصدر عنه نتائج ومن غير المتوقع
ان تعلن النتائج الى وسائل الاعلام لكن
بشكل عام هم يتدارسون كيف ستتحمل هذه
المستشفيات هذا نحن نتحدث عن قطاع يسكن
فيه 2 مليون فلسطيني
وهناك نقص في ادويه مستلزمات وهناك وضع
صعب في القطاع وبالتالي هذه المستشفيات لا
تتحمل
كميه اعداد من الاصابات والجرحى كبيره
الثلاجات الشهداء اصلا لا تتحمل اعداد
كبيره وبالتالي هناك ازمه حقيقيه يمكن ان
تقع اذا استمر هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي كما
تحدث الدكتور محمد ابو سلميه مدير مجمع
الشفاء الطبي قبل قليل للجزيره هذا
الاجتماع سيبقى متواصلا
وبالتاكيد سيعقدون عده اجتماعات للتدارس
حسب تطورات الاوضاع في القطاع واذا استمرت
تصعيد واستمرت الغارات على القطاع